the law of attraction definitely works  most people just get it wrong most  people only focus on the thinking part  and not the most important part which is  the action right law of attraction it's  the last five letters that matter a c t  i o a c t i o n six the last six letters  doesn't matter action action action  thinking about it alone is not enough so  it's the two parts you get an idea you  want something into your life you want  to manifest something amazing you want  success in your business you want a  happy relationship awesome you want to  speak on giant stages whatever the thing  is that you want in your life awesome  you have a vision board amazing just the  fact that you're thinking about it  and believing in it is already a big  step ahead of where most people are most  people live in a negative zone most  people feel like their life is hopeless  that they can't